ja also das ist wirklich wenn man geiles
mehr als zehn autos bestellt ich glaube
das trifft es ganz gut
okay leute aufgepasst 321 elektrosmog
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video
da hatte ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
wir haben heute was ja ein video vor auf
das ich mich eigentlich schon sehr lange
freuen muss ich sagen ich habe es auch
schon das eine oder andere mal
angekündigt ihr seht ihr wie immer im
hintergrund werden dass auch ein schild
wir haben uns im blick
und ja ich hab eigentlich hatte man die
vorstellung diese ganze wand muss voll
mit sohnes eines so heißen die ja
zumindest glaube ich dass sie so heißen
früher habe ich immer gesagt led symbole
oder so auf jeden fall habe ich vor
einiger zeit andere ruhig gestellt die
ich gefunden habe und die frage heute
zusammen aus und ich bin mir noch nicht
sicher ob ich alle da dranhängen und den
kurzen halt bei irgendwie wenn es zu
viele sind sie ist auch scheiße aus so
leute ja ich hab halt ich bin mir nicht
sicher ich habe eigentlich warte mal ich
muss mal ganz kurz nachschauen was
bestellt habe ich eins zwei drei vier
ich dachte eigentlich hätte sechs
bestellt aber anscheinend nicht
na ja ich würde sagen wir fangen wir mit
dem obersten an hier was haben wir denn
hier
ok
als erstes haben wir was er gängiges
muss ich sagen oder
naja was heißt gar nicht ich war mir
nicht sicher ob das cool aussieht ich
habe meinem nächsten stern unten mond
bestellt wahrscheinlich sind in
irgendeinem paket auch mehrere drin
deswegen und hier haben wir jetzt
erstmal den sternen
okay das ding ist wenn man sich auf
wunsch diese ganzen neon science
anschaut es gibt halt so viele anbieter
wie genau das gleiche anbieten also
deswegen sieht das so viel aus aber ich
habe die coolsten genommen und mehr
findet man da eigentlich auch nicht gut
das ist jetzt erst mal überhaupt nichts
besonderes aber geschaut und zwar an
wieder leuchtet weil die farbe weiß ich
nicht mehr davon a
ja also das ist wirklich wenn man geiles
seien auch ruhiggestellt ich glaube das
trifft es ganz gut müll hat benutze ich
auf keinen fall glaube ich sicher dass
sie echt richtig gar nicht was man wie
teuer waren es 12 euro
da muss ich los na ja manche macher
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt zwar
wieder von der gleichen marke
das gibt's doch gar nicht okay
dekoration m
das einzige was man jemand sagen muss
das ist das wo doch made in china
aber die verpackung sind auf englisch
ich weiß nicht was man für so einen
besseren ersten eindruck vielleicht ne
und hier ist jetzt wahrscheinlich der
mode drin weil ich den auch ein erfolg
ok haha was ich aber wirklich sehr gut
finde ist dass das kabel so schön helles
weil ihr seht ja das schwarzem
hintergrund
da muss ich mir noch was einfallen
lassen zum beispiel ein kabelkanal
man das so sieht war das wir haben
bisher nervt das jetzt bin ich mal hier
auf die folter gespannt ja gut
also ich finde ich jetzt irgendwie schon
besser als den stern
aber ich weiß auch nicht ich hänge die
mal kurz daneben ihr könnt ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr am besten
findet und so so jetzt zum beispiel die
wolke hin
ich kann überhaupt nicht einschätzen ob
das heimwegs gut aussieht oder überhaupt
nicht also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich glaube die wolke muss auch im müll
oder nicht in müll aber ich werde nicht
verwendet man der bild zieht finde ich
echt stylisch aus da passt einfach aber
naja machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt jetzt wird's ein bisschen
hochwertiger und auch ein bisschen
besser hoffe ich mache hh okay das ist
schon wirklich ein bisschen größer muss
man sagen wir haben hier ein eis oder
ein eis ist das glaube ich mir fällt auf
ihren ist eine folie drauf wir müssen
wir erstmal 18
hier muss man auch wirklich sagen das
macht direkt von der qualität her einen
viel besseren eindruck haben wir uns so
eine plexiglasscheibe hinter oder so was
ich hoffe jetzt einfach mal das leuchtet
geil und es passt da hin wo auch immer
das kabel ist nur irgendwie ein bisschen
kürzer als bei den anderen
naja schauen wir mal wo alter
das sieht
das siegel nicht schlecht auch das muss
das ist das feld weiter was leuchtet
wirklich also in das eis habe ich mich
jetzt gerade verliebt das ist doch
wirklich schön aus oder fahren auf der
kamera glaub ich komme dass auch gut
rüber das hänge ich auf jeden fall dazu
ja die frage ist nur wo ne ich glaube
ich hole mir sonne sonne leiste sondern
usb-port dann kann ich die dinger
nämlich alle nach einem hämmern ok
weiter weg das hat jetzt bin ich
wirklich mal gespannt was hier drin ist
nein
hey leute ich hab mir so einen erdigen
bestellt das leuchtet rot ich bin euch
hier natürlich auch immer ein foto ein
ich hoffe dass jetzt richtig geil auf
sind das kann ich mir auch so nicht
anders kann ich mir da auch gut
vorstellen
das ding hat mich 22 euro plus 11 euro
versand gekostet also da habe ich da
erwarte ich jetzt schon nasse okay leute
aufgepasst 321 wie ich hat das
manchmal bin ich auch also warte mal ich
muss mir das nicht zu mir das mal kurz
selber oft ich finde es schon geil also
deutsch wir machen mal ganz kurz das
licht aus also leute da muss ich
wirklich sagen das sieht schon richtig
geil aus ich kann mir das schön im
hintergrund vorstellen wie das schön so
pink harmoniert und jetzt gibt euch hier
nochmal das eis also ich glaub es wird
echt heftig ich gehe mal ganz kurz
einkaufen und wohl diese usb den ganzen
und dann hänge ich diese beiden sachen
auf jeden fall schon noch auch weil die
finde ich ultras könnt ihr auch ruhig
zugeben was dort schon schön aussieht
kann man die ware aber noch so eine
kette mit war also das ist schon
professionell okay ich weiß bis gleich
okay da bin ich auch schon wieder also
ich habe mir jetzt mal eben hier so ein
usb h highspeed ja gut sieben ports und
ich habe das jetzt angeklemmt ich muss
sagen wenn es dunkel ist sehr nice aus
wenn es hell ist man sieht halt die
kabel da muss ich mir noch was einfallen
lassen ich glaube selbst wenn
kabelkanäle sind sieht man das ja ja ich
weiß nicht wenn eine idee habt schreibt
gerne in die kommentare
ich mache mir jetzt mal eben das licht
einmal aus und hier auch und leute 3211
nice es ist der ping geworden aber ich
bin auf jeden fall zufrieden axor ja
jetzt sieht das wenigstens so nach einer
wand aus wo man sich vielleicht auch ein
bisschen was bei gedacht hat ja nur halt
hier so mit den kabeln keine ahnung das
ist halt noch nicht optimal
ich habe jetzt trotzdem noch mal für
euch den stern und die wolke mit dem
blitz und dem eis getauscht weil ich ja
eben schon mal so irgendwie sind die
bisschen web und hier könnt ihr das
jetzt versehen da haben wir einmal den
sternen und da haben wir die wolke auf
der kamera sieht es jetzt gar nicht so
schlimm aus aber ich weiß nicht also der
stern ist hier gar nichts für mich wie
gesagt in der comeback und die wolke ist
irgendwie auch nicht so leister ist ein
bisschen komisch der blitz wolke und
stern alle vom selben hersteller aber
wie feiern wir den blitz also wenn wir
so leons heinz zimmer sucht oder so ich
kann euch zum teil die dinger empfehlen
manche sind halt so ist qualität wenn
man derzeit auf kurs
dokumentiert super gerne mal welches von
diesen dingern euch am besten gefällt
was man auch sagen muss wenn die kamera
jetzt auf mein gesicht scharf gestellt
ist und der hintergrund bisschen
unscharf vor allem mit der anderen
kennen die mit einander kennen erzählt
man da halt ein krasses ergebnis so dass
man die habe da gar nicht sieht also ich
denke auch jetzt sieht das schon
deutlich besser aus ich weiß nicht ich
hatte eigentlich noch zwei weiteren
airlines bestellt die sind nicht
angekommen ein bisschen scheiße also
vielleicht komme ich noch irgendwann wir
werden sehen ansonsten ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen abonniert sehr gerne den
kanal daumen nach oben wir sehen uns
morgen wieder gibt's neues video das was
von mir
haut rein